can we just talk about uh where your
general sense of the bull market is like
like
how are you feeling right now in terms
of the sentiment on twitter and how
people kind of are thinking about where
we are
yeah i mean not much has changed uh in
the last week um except you know just
the price action really but um i mean
the bull market's just beginning um you
know one little leverage flush uh you
know a little people get a little
excited over extended uh in derivative
markets that's that's nothing uh you
know fundamentally nothing has changed
with uh the bitcoin bull market and i
think we're right at the beginning
all right so we're gonna pull up uh some
of your slides here we've got this
bitcoin long-term holder supply when you
show this to people i think they're
gonna say wait a second a long-term
holder supply is going down what does
that mean so describe why long-term
holder supply is so important to pay
attention to and then this dip that
we're starting to see what is exactly is
this telling us
yeah so um you know will has been
covering this extensively i've been
paying a lot of attention to this and
covering this myself um and it's
somewhat like counter-intuitive in the
sense that long-term holder supply
drawing down is actually a sign of a
bull market um so basically you know
when you're talking about a supply
squeeze supply a supply squeeze we keep
repeating it right on chain analytics is
like you know this is this is what we're
covering over and over again and why is
this driving the price action well
basically what you're what you're doing
huddling stacking what it's doing is
it's engineering a supply shock and so
that's basically the driver of every
single bull market is there's there's a
fundamental imbalance between supply and
demand there's a lot of you know new
money coming in and they're having to to
compete against basically uh you know
not a lot of the supply so
i you know a lot of these charts i put
together um i showed like a one month
view and then i feel like you know the
entire history of bitcoin and right now
we see uh like basically four straight
days three straight days of drawdowns
and long-term holder supply people might
think that's bad but really what you're
seeing is that the long-term holders are
engineering the supply squeeze and then
when the bull market comes and bitcoin
gets bit up they'll take a little bit of
profit off the table you know just a
proportion of their holdings uh they
distribute to
new market participants and that's fine
uh but that you know that's kind of you
know this is one of the telltale signs
of the bull market kind of kind of
beginning so when we look at the second
chart you have here it's still showing
this long-term holder supply but i think
this is really where you can see that as
the long-term holder supply draws down
that's really where price kind of
punches upwards uh in the market and i
think this is what you're talking about
with that long-term holder supply
contracting a little bit actually
signals the start of that kind of epic
move upwards
yeah i mean so the price action is
almost like the spark of or you know why
they distribute the new holdings right
like you've accumulated during the bear
during consolidation and bitcoin goes
parabolic you know it's okay to take a
little bit off the table um you know
some people will hold forever um but you
know you know if you see an asset that
you hold go up ten thousand percent a
thousand percent you know double 5x
whatever it is um you're gonna maybe
take some take something off the table
so that's what you see here every time
bitcoin goes parabolic um just like it
did you know when it went 6x from
september of last year to you know march
or april you saw a long-term holder
supply drawdown basically the whole time
and new market participants came in and
basically you know acquired all that
bitcoin and so now you know when we were
talking last week or a couple weeks ago
and every time will comes on he's
talking about and he's showing you these
same charts and he's saying hey like
look it uh we're seeing kind of like
almost like a bear market dynamic where
long-term holders are are stacking or
stacking their butt off and so you know
now i think we're right at the beginning
stages of this next parabolic advance
where you're going to have you know a
club a demand of new money come in and
they're just gonna you know it's they
don't have much to bid they're gonna
have to bid reflexively in a small super
small flow of you know free supply and
that's really what happened back in
october november december and into q1 of
2021 right was that there was very
little supply available that was kind of
liquid people came in they were like hey
i'll buy it at 12 000
no one was selling 15 20 25 30 and we
just ran all the way up to 64 000
because literally it took that much
price movement or i like to think of it
as like the us dollar price has to move
upwards to accommodate everyone in terms
of the new demand and then also
unlocking right it's almost like you
have an asset you really like it uh and
they're bidding on it right literally
they're saying i'll pay you a certain
price and bitcoin is like i'm not
selling i'm not selling and then
eventually like okay fine i'll still
take 64 thousand dollars like idiot
right right and that's where they're
actually gonna go ahead and sell but
everyone has a different price that
they'll do that at
yeah the bitcoin price moves up when the
marginal seller is exhausted and i think
that's that's the key um you know
there's there's a few willing sellers in
this market and you can see it on chain
um you know a couple million bitcoin are
basically being washed rated back and
forth and the people these traders you
know they'll set limit orders still
they'll have you know market sells where
they take some profit um and there's
obviously there's leverage on top of
that so you know when you're looking at
certain price actions just like the last
couple days why is bitcoin going down i
thought all-time highs were broken well
you know there's derivatives on top of
that which we'll you know we'll cover in
a little bit but you know the
fundamental driver of a bull market
is you have
the free flow of supply is has you know
gone really really thin and you're
having this new kind of club of demand
coming and so they have to just
reflexively bid up the price of bitcoin
and so when you see long-term holders
start to distribute a little bit that's
fine and that's just showing you that
the new money is coming in and acquiring
that that supply bitcoin's changing
hands so we have this chart the long
term and short term holder on chain cost
basis what is this showing us
yeah so the cool thing about you know on
chain analytics is we can see basically
the average price of these cohorts we
can see the long term holder you know
basically cost basis the price that they
acquired their coins and the short term
holder cost basis so the short term is
the pink and it's basically pretty it
follows price you know pretty closely
and the long-term holder supply is
obviously lags a little bit and you see
you see during bull markets you see the
short-term holder cost basis you know
get bid up huge while the long-term
holder cost basis kind of stays flat or
i mean rises marginally and so a bear
market dynamics is when is when these
two are converging upon each other in a
bull market dynamic is when is when one
kind of the short term holder cost basis
really really really gets bit and so
when you put these two in a ratio you
can kind of see over that over the
history of bitcoin you can see like a
really interesting pattern uh of bull
and bear cycles um based on on these two
cost bases uh you know for the long term
and short term holders got it and then
we've got a second visualization of kind
of the same thing as cost basis ratio uh
what what is this showing us that's a
little bit different from that first one
yeah so this is just the two in a ratio
and so the green uh in this chart is
essentially showing a bull market
dynamic where where these short term
holders the price of their you know uh
of their holdings is it's going up a lot
because you have all this new money
coming in right this is the dynamic we
were talking about with the long-term
holders and the short-term holders
coming in and really trying the new
money coming in and really trying to you
know acquire their stake um they're
having to to bid against each other
competitively and so the price of
bitcoin skyrockets their average cost
basis skyrockets and you can see this
with green right this is the the green
zones are when the short term hold their
cost basis is skyrocketing relative to
the long term and so um you know
conversely when when the there's this
red zone here that's when the long-term
cost basis is is creeping up against the
short term and so that's kind of like a
consolidation or a bear market dynamic
and interestingly enough the last couple
months over the course of the summer we
saw basically like an on-chain bear
market even though even though price
action wasn't uh well you know wasn't
too bearish over the last couple months
you saw just basically this is showing
like a massive accumulation um by
convicted long-term holders and so now
we're just now like a couple days ago we
kind of this ratio turned up and is
actually now it's like you can think of
it as green so we're in this i think
we're in the beginning stages of the
bull market and a lot of the stuff we
look at on chain
you know is saying the same thing and
this fifth slide is this is just uh
zoomed in a little bit right there on on
the kind of that turn up in that green
uh signal
yeah so this is just like the really up
close uh version of it and so we can
kind of see that that ratio is just
starting to turn a little bit so so i
kind of think of this as the reflexive
kind of parabolic phase of the bull
market uh is just starting up we uh we
just kind of entered that enter that
zone
yeah it's incredible to kind of just see
how clearly you can you can identify
this with the unchained metrics